did the State Department know anything
about what you were doing State
Department asked me to help them deal
with the Ukrainian government with
regard to meetings with President Trump
State Department investigate crime I was
asked to do this by the State Department
I didn't know mr. Yarmuth from a hole in
the wall the name of your Mac was given
to me by Kurt Vogel ambassador I was
asked to meet with him I did meet with
him i briefed them two of them on
everything I did and I have a very nice
text at the end explaining how honest
and straightforward I was which is which
I am did the secretary of state might
Pompeii or did he know if he didn't know
we read about in the newspaper but
within a few days so and then after
reading about it he had his people
contact me to help them and I have a
wonderful note back from them but what a
good job I did I mean are you telling me
some of them are now running away from
it but this is Washington very few
people are straight direct like I have
no right as a non-government employee to
investigate them to freelance ultimately
I wasn't freelancing why do you say
things like that I mean I there's no
basis on which you should say that I'm
freelancing the reality is that there is
an alternative theory of how this crime
was committed and the crime was
committed by Democrats and as his lawyer
it's my obligation to establish those
facts you don't have any issue with a
foreign power investigating a political
rival if the president I do if you
didn't do anything but if he bribed the
president of that country I have an
issue if they don't investigate so the
ends justify the means no opposite way
around it'd be totally illegitimate not
to investigate it if a president if a
vice president the United States go
somewhere and extort the president of
that country or bribes the president of
that country to get his son out of
trouble I'd find it extraordinary if
they didn't investigate are you at all
concerned about your future because you
very happy place is a central role in
this no I'm not concerned about my
future what I did is perfectly lawful
perfectly legal I find it completely
extraordinary that you're spending all
this time asking me
about what I did all this time should be
spent on the pay-for-play scheme the
Biden setup in which he made millions
and billions of dollars using his son
and having his son sell his office that
should shock you but because we are
distorted this left-wing distortion that
goes on you're asking me about the
process that I followed to uncover one
of the biggest scandals I should be
considered a whistleblower
I should be getting whistleblower
protection I actually found facts that
are true the other guy half of what he
wrote is false the Ukrainians today say
that when they investigated this
prosecutor Joe Biden's son wasn't even
working for the gas company
what are they lying yes yeah yeah it was
what he began working for there you just
read the New York Times he began working
for this company in 2015 he didn't stop
working through the company in two
months ago and the the investigation was
tanked meaning dropped in 2016 so that's
completely untrue at the heart of this
we know is a whistleblower who alleges
that the president tried to interfere
with the 2020 election and then the
White House covered it up do you in
principle regard both of those things as
potentially serious offenses so here's
what he says here's what he says I am
deeply concerned I was told I heard
based on my understanding I learned I do
not know you know you know the word
isn't here the verb that isn't here no
there's no place here I know I know
I know he's not a witness to anything he
heard gossip he's telling you what other
people said to him most of which when
you look at the recording turn out to be
wrong if there was nothing wrong with
the call then why did the White House
put it on a separate electronic City
cause yeah obviously was some kind of
interference in this somebody was going
out talking about it which by the way is
a crime this
I mean if shame to call how to be put
out these calls should remain secret if
a if a president of the United States
and the Prime Minister of England can't
talk without fear of its being exposed
all over the place can you imagine how
that's going to restrict their
conversations the White House has a
legitimate interest in keeping these
calls confidential not because there's
anything wrong with what they're doing
but because there's something very
confidential about it you could you
could give away information that can you
have people killed in conversations
between heads of state about military
movements about things that have to do
with criminal offenses involving
organized crime or my goodness it's one
of these conversations has never been
put out that wasn't the case with this
cool though no it wasn't the case with
this call but the reality is the people
who have to secure it don't know when
and if someone's gonna intercept one of
those conversations is very damaging so
by the time this one was leaking the
caps out of the bag but you want to
protect it in the future
so there are a lot more calls
potentially that are held back and have
been put on this is every call every
call every every call from a head of
state he's secured as best we can secure
I don't know what the White House did so
I'm not familiar with exactly what they
did but if they tried to ramp up their
security for these calls that was a very
good thing to do and a very normal thing
to do if you had fear that things were
leaking out about a conversation with a
head of state it's not supposed to
happen do it else that doesn't have to
be an explicit mention of money there
was mention of money you don't you don't
try to create things that aren't there
there is a record of the conversation if
that conversation doesn't talk about
military aid military aid was not
involved in this situation there are a
lot of reasons you can withhold aid
including the general problem of
corruption in the Ukraine and your
desire to get more done to help that
plenty of reasons if that were involved
in this situation it would have been in
that conversation now I can add to that
if it was involved in this situation I
surely would have known about it with
all of the conversations that I had I
never heard about military aid this was
a this is a Democrat issue that's put
into it and even if there was foreign
aid involved it pales in comparison of
what Joe Biden did which is exquisite so
do you fear the president could be
impeached the president do anything
wrong
president do adawn thing wrong when you
look at that conversation there's no
threat there's no quid pro quo there's
no mention of money if you want to
interpret something well I can't stop
you from interpreting something that's
cold I like making it up it's either
there or it isn't there it isn't there I
have no fear of that do I have a fear
that the Democrats might vote for
something that's what I'm asking it get
voted never get through the Senate and
they'll kill themselves if they do it I
mean it's stupid politically there are
40 Democrats from states where from
districts where Trump won last time you
think they're gonna get returned to
office the American people like 60 70
percent against impeachment that's what
I was asking do you think the Democrats
will vote to impeach how do I know what
they're gonna do there they do things
that have amazed me and they get away
with things did amaze me are you willing
to testify in front of Congress well
there's a lot of problems with that I
mean what I like to testify and tell my
story sure I've been telling it all the
time in fact you know my story nothing I
can tell them that you can't read online
from the very beginning I've been
totally transparent about this there are
things that I can't testify to because
I'm a lawyer well as the president said
to you this week he asked me how I'm
doing we talked about golf and anything
we talked about relating to the case I
can't tell you